this is your Tech news briefing for
Tuesday April 4th I'm Zoe Thomas for The
Wall Street Journal
Apple has taken steps to solve one of
music's biggest problems finding the
perfect recording of your favorite
classical music piece
to do this the tech giant has come out
with a new Standalone app for
subscribers of its music streaming
service called Apple music classical
now if you listen to a lot of classical
music you may be breathing a sigh of
relief and if you're more of a hip-hop
rock or pop fan you may be wondering how
did this become a problem at all well
our science of success columnist Ben
Cohen is with us to explain how the
problem arose and how Apple stepped
forward to deal with it hey Ben thanks
for joining us hi so let's start with
this problem why is it hard to find
classical music to stream when I can
find you know other music super easily
so there are really two problems the
first is that there is a lot of
classical music to be more specific
there are a lot of recordings of the
same repertoire and the second problem
is the way that classical music is
categorized and to be more specific
there it is categorized completely
differently than the way that we
categorize pop music which makes it
really hard for classical music to be
discovered in this streaming era that
optimizes for pop music okay so it
doesn't follow the rules of pop what is
it about the algorithm that's optimized
for pop that just doesn't quite fit with
classical music and how that is labeled
so the issue is that a pop song There
are really like three labels that matter
it's title artist album right so if you
think about a Taylor Swift song the
three pieces of information that matter
are like anti-hero by Taylor Swift on
the album midnights right and there may
be a few covers of that song but the
version of the song that people want to
listen to is Taylor Swift that's the
only one that really matters now if you
think about any piece of classical music
it is totally different so you have the
name of the track and you also have the
name of the artist who records that
track and the name of the composer who
came up with that particular piece of
repertoire but one piece might be
separated into multiple movements right
and there is an opus number and a
nickname and a key and a period and an
instrument and like there are all sorts
of different information that you might
want to input when you are searching for
classical music in Spotify or apple
music or any other popular streaming
platform and that completely breaks the
algorithm to the point that if you want
to find like one version of The sibelius
Violin Concerto good luck it's just
going to be almost impossible so what
we're talking about really is is
metadata I'm sure many listeners know
metadata is the information that this
describes other data so what did Apple
do to try and address this so they
really did two things the first thing
they did was they bought a small Dutch
company a few years ago called Prime
phonic that was a classical only
music streaming platform there were a
few of them that exist they have some
other competitors and what prime phonic
had done was compile this really
comprehensive database of metadata where
they were manually typing in all of this
information that would make it easier to
sort through classical music so Apple
bought them because they wanted to solve
this problem and even a company worth
two and a half trillion dollars couldn't
really do it by themselves so they buy
Prime phonic they shut the product down
in 2021 and last week they launched a
standalone product dedicated to
classical music called Apple music
classical it is this what we call a
bespoke product for the Baroque Period
and Beyond and you know it's sort of
unusual because you wouldn't think of
the world's most valuable company
launching a new product or service that
is solely for streaming classical music
right but I think how they solve this
problem applies to many other problems
and as you said it is this issue of
metadata and how it's sort of one of the
secrets to organizing the universe so
what could Apple's experience in
tackling metadata as it relates to
classical music teach them for you know
other Technologies or other problems
that they might come against well I
think they have this problem with the
Apple music product itself not just
Apple music classical but Apple music
and can they do it for jazz can they do
it for Indian music I think there is a
real hunger for more information and
better information about the information
that we consume on a daily basis and so
when you think about whether it's apple
or whether it's Netflix showing us stuff
that we really want to see or chat GPT
giving us answers that we can't find
anywhere else on the internet I think
more metadata means better data means
like giving us sharper answers to the
questions that we have so with it sounds
like what you're saying is this isn't
just a music problem this is really a
search problem or potentially a solution
to a search problem I think that's right
and I think for a company like apple
that sold 200 billion dollars of iPhones
last year anything that they can do to
make the iPhone slightly more valuable
even on like a very marginal basis like
classical music makes it worth their
while and it's interesting to see them
experimenting in this space and will be
even more interesting to see how the
results of this experiment influence
everything else that they do are they
funding problems
or backs to
to Classic yes so
the service is not perfect yet right
even though they have cleaned up the
listings a bunch of them are still very
messy like the metadata is not perfect
there are also some other issues like
it's only available in the US right now
it's not available around the world yet
and also Apple says it's the largest
catalog of classical music ever
assembled but it's still not complete
what Apple says is that the search for
perfection in classical music is the
longest piece of string imaginable which
is a quote that I love and that this is
just the beginning and that the product
will be much better a year from now than
it is this week or it was on the first
day have any of their competitors in the
music streaming space tried to tackle
this issue so there are some smaller
Niche services for classical music only
like Adagio which also you know spotted
this problem of metadata and tried to
solve it in a similar way it was founded
in 2015 and when I called the founder of
Adagio last week I was sort of expecting
him to be shaking in his boots a little
bit now that he's competing against the
world's most valuable company and he did
not sound all that intimidated and
basically said you know I think it's
great that a key player in this space is
finally paying attention and there is a
role for the David in this story and
also the Goliath the really interesting
thing to me will be if Spotify follows
Apple here so Spotify is like easily the
giant of the streaming space and if you
look for classical music on Spotify it
is a rough Journey you sort of feel like
you've been transported back to the 17th
century a little bit if you're trying to
find the piece that you're looking for
so it will be really interesting to me
to see if Spotify follows the lead of
Apple here and cleans up some of its own
classical music offerings that's our
science of success columnist Ben Cohen
thanks for joining us Ben thank you and
that's it for today's Tech news briefing
for more Tech stories head over to our
website
wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]